L
ABBOTT HASD POSITIVE FVIRUS.
ABBOTT IS FULLATED AND
EXPERIENCING NCOMPINCHADDED IN
TESTING WHILING E
VIDEO SHARED BHI ON
TWITTER SHOWS THE VEN A
DUNGGHT.
EVAS BEEN
GERENOTIECOVID WS,
THIS TIME IN FLORIDA WHERE THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCAON IS
HOLDING ME
RIGH CONSIDE
ABOUT SC DTS THAT HAVED MASKAND
OVERNOR R
HD TO WITHHOLD  OFFICIAW MASK M
MEETING'T WE'RE
TOLD BY R THE MANDATORY OFMASKS
ABOUT LLLES?
orter:
AND THE EDUCATION COMMISSIONER
N FLORIDISY
RE THAT THBOD
ENFORCE -- USES THEIR FORCEMENTT
TWO SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
PARTICULAR, BROWARD AND ALACA
T  C THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE
THE SUPERINTENDENT FROM ALACHUA
JUST T.D PUBLIC COMMENTS
JUST ME
THIS IS
SOINE VERY
L VERY QUICK
WE ALSO HEAR OF THE PUBLICACKIN
COMMENO DOWN THAT SAME
ROUTE.
TELL YOUROM THE
SCHOOL BOARDECKED  A LOT OEMARE
ANIS STATE WHERE WE
JUST GOT THIS REPORTIN0 D 11,00
CT THE STATE.
SCHO HT EVENN SOME
OF THE LARGEST DISTRICTS.
OWG TOMORROWMII- DAYS AWAY
ASELAGIN MIAMI
FLA,O CHTHE  MANDATEXTENDED WHIP
LEJANUARY.
LET'S BRING IN CNN'S C CORRESPO
DEMOCRAT REPUBLICANS
SCG ON THE
E NS.
IT'S ABOUT TCI
IE, A KE MORE SENSE THAN A
?
>>EL I THINK THEY'RE BOT
IMPORTANT.
AND THAT SKIRT
QUESTION, JAKE.
BUT I THINK A LOT OF TIMES EEHEG
SICK IF THEY HAVE BEEN EXPOSED.
T MASKAKE,
RIW BECAE IS SO AL TRANSMISSION
ALING SHOWERED IN VIRUS,
START TO THINK
FTINANTEBUT THEY'RLITTLE BIT
DIFFT.T MIGHT BE A
ATOPLE SHOULD
MAES WHEN
INTHAT, THEY STUCK STORM. MANDA
WITH IT EVEN WHEN C SORT
OF GUIDANCE IN  O
PLANES YOU S HADO SKS.SICALL
SAYING THERE'S
STILL A LOT OF VIRUS OUTRE.T TH.
I THINK VACCIN ARE
COMING IN MA PLACE A
BRS.T DEO HAVE TINATED YOU DON'S
S OTPOSITIVE. SYMPTOM
SO WHY WOULD HE  TREATED WIT
GECLONAL ANTIBODY
IF HE'S T >> THERE'S BEEN A COU
STUDIES AROUND THIS NO
SICALLY, BRO MONOCLONABODIES, T
ISEP P
HOSPITAL.
PRIMARILY D MILD THET THEY WERE
SYERE AT TIALLY HAVING TO GO TO.
AND THEY FOUND THA VERY
AND HEAL CACY THERE.
LOOKING ATOPLE
COGH OD OF NEEDSPITALIZ. WIBODI
PPOSED.
ANTIBODIES.THE VACCINES IN
THEY TEACH YOUR BO HOWKEDI REGOE
BODIES.
ATT
E POINT IS TO EM EAR WHEN EILY O
AND ITPREVENT TH
DISEASE AND  NEEDING
TO BE HOSPITALIZED.
>> THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS O
ADULTS A DWH
LE U.S. POPULATIONILL REFUSES T
BOOSTERS STILGHT
PRIORITY AS PO HAVING
THE IN
>> I TENTIONING ARE L WON'T G
PRIO.
AND I KNOW THERE'S LOT OF
ABOUT THIS BACK AND
TO A LOT OF PEOPLE
OU, ANPE HAV VIEWSN THIS.
THE PE WE F THE S
HOSPITALAR
UNVA
MOST OF THE TRANSMISSION THAT'OR
BECAUSE OFHEACCINA GOO
SHOW THAT THE VACCINE IS
ACTUALLY TERMSS
EFFECTIVENESS.
INTHERE RE ME OF THIS DATA BECAE
LET ME SHOWHAT DATA
HAVE.
A AT ENCING THEIR
HI PEOPLE VE  THIS IAINST AL
SYMPTOMS, TS MABEOWED UP AT TH
BUT E  A LOTF
PEOPUT THERE WHOE LAVE WITBREAKN
TH THE NEXT GRAPH I'T OF
CRITICAL ONE.
AND THAT HAS BWEESE VACCINESPLI
OUMEASURES THAEY
ORIGINALLY ARE INTENDED TO
ACCOMPLISH, H IS TO KEEP
FROM GETTING SEVERELY
IT QUITE00% ANYMORE, BUT
IT'S VERY CLOSE TOMS
I THINK WHAT THEY'REO
HAVE IS SQUARES IDEA
ANDHE
YEFOR  CONSIDERED ERR IMMUNOCOM
SOME REASRE AND O T BOOSTERS T
NU
T TERRIBLEOF COLD IN MY DAD, FO
WHOSE TO 8
USN
WOULD BE A MUCH MORE SIGNIFICAN.
I THINK IT'O KE THE WHEN SO
MUCH OF THE WOS SIMPLY NOTD ACC.
>>ABAT VACCINE.
WILL THET A SE
>>HIOF
FRUSTRATION
T MORE EMAILS AND SOCIAL
ABOUT THIS THA ELSE.THIS UHERE.
CDC.RI TTHIS DOWN ENT OM
A LI BVE YOUEA
OFEY'RE NG
22 MILLION OR SO I BELIEVE
PEOPLEE RECEIVED THIS.
AND THEYSE
VACCINES LATER SE'S LESS
E THAT BOOST
AY THEY'RENG
REAS DETAILEANABOUT THIS
A TO
WHAT WE'T TOMOARDING
MODERNA AND PFIZ
BUT I KNOW A LOT OF PEOP
T DATA.
THERE'S FEWE ANDT'S
LESS TIME THAT THE
BEEN OUTHEL SIGNALS
THCTHA
NECESSARY.
D ES LIKVE
KIDS UNDER 12 TO BE ABLE TO GEP
A FROM AS TO I WIT OLDER KIDS U
RT CASE OU B
THISUSG SOMEF THAT DATA.
YOUNGER THAN THAT, THEY'RELOOK,
ARE THINGS THA DIME FRAME, PUBE
MAY CHANGE HOW PE AR
METABOLIZINGACCINE.
BUT I THINIT
GETTING THE  A